This morning President-elect Donald Trump
officially named his pick to lead the environmental
protection agency,
Oklahoma Attorney General Scott Pruitt.
The swearing in ceremony took place in the
White House Treaty Room
with Supreme Court Justice Samuel Alito administering
the oath.
Trump’s EPA chief came into office determined
to end what he dubbed
the agency’s “anti-energy agenda,”
by loosening requirements on carbon emissions
and eliminating land use restrictions.
Pruitt has set out to transform the agency
he leads
perhaps to a greater extent than any of Trump’s
other cabinet appointees.
We as an agency, and we as a nation, can be
both pro-energy and jobs and pro-environment.
One of his biggest targets:
a controversial rule on water pollution put
in place by the Obama administration.
You had a power grab that was taking place
at the EPA
where they were trying to assert jurisdiction
over land use decisions
that were being made by private property owners
and cities and towns in states across the country.
Progressives were outraged.
He is going to dismantle everything in place.
The air you breathe, the water you drink.
To understand why property rights advocates
applauded Pruitt’s move,
consider the case of fourth-generation farmer
John Duarte,
who has fought a protracted and costly legal
battle with federal regulators
over how to till his 450 acre farm in Tehama
County, California.
If the government can do this to us
there’s no family in America who can farm
their land
without concern the government can come on
to their property
and take everything they own.
My family’s farming history goes back to
my great grandfathers.
We produce grapevines, almond trees, pistachio
trees, walnuts, avocados,
and a few other minor crops.
The government is saying that our tillage
of this ground to plant a wheat crop
violated the Clean Water Act.
In 2012 the Army Corps of Engineers, working
in conjunction with the EPA,
accused Duarte of damaging wetland features
on his property.
The penalty: over $30 million in fines and
restoration fees.
But getting permission before plowing wasn’t
really an option.
The average time to obtain a Clean Water Act
permit is close to two years.
And the average cost just to hire the consultants
and do the studies to get permits approaches
a quarter of a million dollars.
Attorney Anthony Francois with the Pacific
Legal Foundation
represented Duarte in his case against the
government.
Clearly if you had to undertake that kind
of cost and time
just to get the necessary permit to plow your
fields every year
you’re not going to grow a lot of food.
Duarte’s troubles stemmed from a provision
in the Clean Water Act
known as the Waters of the United States rule
that was meant to better protect large bodies of water
by regulating use of the streams, ponds, and
ditches that flow into them.
But in a power grab by agency bureaucrats,
Obama’s EPA expanded the power granted by
this provision,
using it as license to micromanage private
land use to the point of absurdity.
The agency accused Duarte of mismanaging the
wetland areas located on his property,
claiming that his four inch plow furrows created
small mountain ranges.
Not those mountains, these ones.
That’s what we have right here, in these
furrows.
They’re saying the bottom of this furrow
is still a wetland.
But the top of this furrow—five inches higher—is
a converted upland.
Attorney generals from 31 states, including
Pruitt,
challenged the Obama administration’s overreach
on the Clean Water Act.
The broad trend of environmental regulation
during the Obama administration
was to use the coercive threat or reality
of regulation
simply to try to shut down entire industries
and entire types of economic activity.
That’s University of Virginia law professor
Jason Scott Johnston.
He says that the Obama administration expanded
the definition of wetlands
beyond the parameters set by the Supreme Court
in a 2007 decision.
They have promulgated a definition of wetlands
which clearly contradicts what the Supreme Court said.
They're going to go out and regulate things
that they consider to be wetlands,
even though this Court has said they're not.
EPA’s so-called Waters of the United States
rule
is one of the worst examples of federal regulation
and it has truly run amok.
The Trump Administration has started the process
of repealing the rule,
but faces multiple legal hurdles and getting
it off the books could take several years.
Faced with millions of dollars in fines,
Duarte settled his case in August for $1.1
million.
He hopes Pruitt’s focus on regulatory rollback
will restore the property rights of farmers.
We become peasants where these federal prosecutors
can come in like the Sheriff of Nottingham,
decide for themselves what they think a family
can pay,
decide for themselves if they want to destroy
a family and take their land away.
If the federal prosecutors can come on this
farm with this set of facts
there is no farm in America that is safe from
this kind of prosecution.